le président de gaulle remet sa
démission c'était le 27 avril 1969
comment en est-il arrivé là
retour en mai 68
face à la révolte étudiante et ouvrière
après dix ans au pouvoir
la place du chef de l'état est menacée
[Musique]
à
la réponse de de gaulle une mutation
profonde du pays
il propose de renforcer le pouvoir des
régions est de transformer le sénat le
peuple va s'exprimer par voie de
référendum
françaises français au mois de juin
vous vous prononcerez par un vote bien
plus qu'en vote c'est un ultimatum au
cas où votre réponse serait non il va de
soi que je n'assumerai pas plus
longtemps la fonction en 1969 les
français doivent répondre à une double
question approuvez vous le projet de loi
relatif à la création de régions et à la
rénovation du sénat derrière cette
question c'est le maintien du président
à son poste qui se joue faites vous
confiance au général de gaulle pour
l'appliquer le camp gaulliste se
concentre plus sur le maintien du
général que sur la défense de la réforme
la réforme régionale
elle est très important mais plus
importante
la fidélité au général de gaulle que
nous a rendus launay l'indépendance et
la paix en coulisses le président doute
il s'engage une nouvelle fois à partir
en cas d'échec
si je suis désavoué par une majorité
d'entre vous je cesserai aussitôt
d'exercer mes fonctions le 27 avril 1969
80 % des électeurs se rendent aux urnes
le nom l'emportent à 50 2 58%
le président tient sa parole il annonce
sa démission dans la nuit confirmé la
journée du 28 avril le général de gaulle
avait rendu public le communiqué suivant
je cesse d'exercer mes fonctions de
président de la république
cette décision prend effet aujourd'hui à
midi charles de gaulle premier président
de la cinquième république et provenir
démissionnaire après deux mois d'intérim
par le président du sénat alain poher
les français élisent georges pompidou le
15 juin 1969
[Musique]